this is a Sky News special live from
turkey's earthquake zone where time is
running out to reach survivors still
clinging onto life under the rubble
here and in Syria the need for help
right now is urgent as this region faces
the ultimate test
[Music]
coming up we'll meet the desperate
families digging with basic tools and
their bare hands
now we are dying here
there is hope for some and incredible
escapes too including for this little
girl pulled to Safety in Syria
more than 11
000 people are known to have died with
fears that numbers could triple
with their homes destroyed thousands now
live in the freezing cold we'll report
from the mountain towns decimated and
without power
[Music]
coming up we'll assess what caused this
disaster and why this region is so
vulnerable to the forces of nature
where are you
and we hear the plea of a man far from
home I join armit from South Wales on
his mission to reach his family
[Music]
hello it's six o'clock here in Ufa and
it's three o'clock in the afternoon in
the UK and this is a Sky News special
program in the devastating aftermath of
the worst disaster to hit this region
for more than 80 years
when that 7.8 magnitude earthquake
struck Southeastern turkey and also
Northwestern Syria early on Monday
morning Tremors were felt right across
the Middle East and as the day unfolded
so did the scale of this tragedy 11
000 people confirmed dead nearly 5 000
buildings destroyed tens of thousands of
families without homes in freezing
conditions and from those who survived
here and across the border in Syria the
message we've been hearing loud and
clear is we need more help
and we need it now
Sky news correspondents have reached
some of the worst affected areas right
across turkey
from the devastated gazian's depth to
the epicenter right down to the border
with Syria they've been hearing first
hand how people here have been
struggling to survive
in antakia south west of here the fury
of residents left to fend for themselves
deepens by the hour
our special correspondent Alex Crawford
is there a warning that coming up you'll
see attempts to resuscitate a child who
subsequently died which many of our
viewers may find distressing
We Begin the program with Alex's Special
Report on this country's desperate
search for survivors
they're using bits of rubble
whatever they can get their hands on to
reach those buried
[Music]
can anyone hear me she's shouting
they can hear sounds
[Music]
so they keep calling and listening for
the loved ones who lived here
they've come with little more than
courage and a great deal of Hope
and their tools make barely any impact
on an eight-story building now all on
the ground floor
relatives look on sick with worry
bubbling anger growing inside
any additional machines to supply our
machines we have no support yet from the
government
we have now Four Towers no one comes
nobody nobody are here to touch this and
start from the 40 hour I am the one
waiting here for 40 hours no one can is
came an area here to touch now we are
buying here no dying okay just dying
they stand in huddles weeping and find
Comfort by talking to the trapped
children they may never see again
be strong then he is she's saying to him
be strong we are here
Fury is real and raw the government's
not here she's shouting enough enough
this city which hugs the Syrian border
appears to be one of the worst hit it's
home to a huge number of Syrian refugees
who fled the war to safety here and the
hatai mayor is from the main opposition
party stoking suspicions that this may
have contributed to the little Aid
evident here
we saw residents helping themselves to
food and supplies from a supermarket
which had been broken into but also saw
a television being carted away
it's because we're hungry one man told
us
inspiration is haunting this city
for the love of God please help us help
but it begs us God I'm waiting for help
she says her husband's trapped upstairs
and they're flat and has poor sight
please I expect help from my government
there's so many people who feel they're
not getting the help that they need
not one person he tells us we haven't
seen a single soul here
we don't even have any water to drink or
even have any bread to eat she goes on
daughters in there with her two kids
another man tells us they've died in
that house
[Applause]
there are moments of sheer Joy a young
baby is pulled out
after so many hours she is a real living
Miracle
she's too young to remember what
happened but her family will remind her
she's one who beat the odds on turkey's
terrible day of earthquakes
the baby's mother has somehow kept her
alive and she too has been found they're
both badly dehydrated and the young mum
looks traumatized
this has been a terrifying experience
for them all
there are questions about how well
prepared they were here for a disaster
long predicted to happen but every time
someone is coats to safety and guided
down the piles of broken concrete which
were once their homes it inspires The
Rescuers to keep on going
there are far more suffering far too
many mothers consumed by grief as the
wafer than hope they were clinging onto
finally disappears
The Rescuers don't give up though there
are frantic efforts to try to
resuscitate her boy they try and they
keep on trying
but this is a young life they cannot
save
this region is probably uniquely
ill-equipped to cope with a natural
disaster of this scale and the heartache
and grief is going to grow over the next
few days and weeks
Alex joining us now live from antakia
Alex there is certainly a distinct sense
now that time is running out
time is critical in conditions like this
okay every hour every minute counts look
at what they're having to face in in at
the moment I mean there are houses
apartment blocks even hospitals right
next to me which have collapsed and
there is kilometer after kilometer here
in hattai we're in nantaki which is
probably one of the worst impacted
places in the whole of the country and
there has been a marked improvement in
the tempo here there have been a flood
of volunteers age groups mechanical
diggers all sorts of groups rushing to
the area to help president erdogan has
heard the complaints and he has reacted
he spent today visiting the earthquake
zones and he's just landed a few minutes
ago before we came on air here in hatai
he's admitted that he made mistakes that
there were problems in the first day but
now he says it's under control well I
think the residents here will take issue
with the under control bit because
they're still very much in Desperate
straight we saw a short while ago the
first international team of search and
rescue team groups to arrive here they
are from Britain the 76 person team from
Britain landed a couple of hours ago
they set to work and within minutes of
their arrival here on the ground they
were besieged by civilians begging them
to help they say they're going to stay
here and their aim is to try to save
lives but yes every minute counts
Alex Crawford thank you
well today people standing helpless
among the rubble of their flattened
homes were sent a message from the
country's president as tens of thousands
of people question why they're receiving
so Little Help from the authorities
today as Alex was saying I promise that
nobody will be forced to cope alone
we're carrying on managing with the
rubble God willing we will start to
remove the rubble God willing our aim is
to rebuild houses in one year as we
already did previously in areas hit by
earthquakes our people must not worry we
won't allow any of our citizens to be
left in the streets
so what's the reality is help really
reaching those who need it most the city
of Caravan Mirage is nearly 50 miles
that's around 80 kilometers north of
here towards uh the earthquakes
epicenter uh International correspondent
John Sparks is there John you're in one
of the worst affected areas is help
getting in there
afterwards
Mark that is a it's a very very good
question and I don't know the answer
certainly a lot of people here who are
very unhappy with the situation don't
think they've had anywhere near enough
help in fact where we are I'm going to
show you a few pictures in a minute it's
quite extraordinary what they were
telling us this morning was that they'd
only just started to see rescue teams
and heavy Vehicles this morning I'll
tell you where we are I mean we are
close to both epicenters on Monday this
is a housing estate a housing
Precinct called the Abra site and there
were nine apartment blocks here up to 11
stories high they have been pulled and
pushed off their foundations and this is
a scene it's an apocalyptic scene of
total devastation and what was happening
earlier there were volunteers local
people trying to pull bodies out
through the concrete cracks in these
buildings they said they could hear
the voices of people as well telephones
ringing in these blocks as well they
were trying to get people out but a
decision has been made these diggers
have arrived and they are now
tearing what's left of these buildings
apart and I can tell you that we have
seen
body bags being removed small amounts of
equipment coming in and I'm going to ask
my colleague Olivia just to focus on the
people looking on many of those people
have their friends their loved ones
their relatives inside that building
they know they're there
and they are waiting they have to wait
to see what happens it's uh totally
agonizing process for them
that's the scene bitterly cold here
they'll be working through the night
scene of total devastation here in
Carolina barrage
John thank you very much indeed and I
should say it is a scene repeated right
across this region and it's clear that
even anyone who managed to survive the
Tremors themselves is now struggling to
withstand uh the really freezing
temperatures here only at worsening this
tragedy of course families desperately
searching the rubble rescue teams
sifting through the wreckage all
fighting the wintry weather that
threatens to make this disaster even
more deadly
well north of the epicenter in the afsin
region snow is hampering the effort to
find the missing our correspondent
Siobhan Robbins is there
so we've come to one of the rural
villages in the afshan area of turkey
it's north of the epicenter but you can
see buildings here families still
affected here the whole roof has
collapsed it looks like side of the
building also has come down as well and
that's not the only problem facing
people here you can also see when we
swing round that they've lost power in
some of the places in this Village so
the power line down here but also a very
badly damaged family home there you can
see blankets popping out the side the
roof again has collapsed and then the
whole front of the building has been
totally exposed with the rubble falling
onto what is potentially the family car
and the problem for people living in
rural areas like this is firstly access
to Aid we've spoken to volunteers who've
managed to get here and they said that
no government Aid has come here yet that
the government is focusing on the cities
they have no idea when they'll come to
places like this where there are 600 odd
people living so instead volunteers are
doing what they can they're focusing on
giving people blankets because of the
bitter cold giving people toilet paper
trying to give people water as well with
the power down that's another problem as
well that families here are facing but
also if you have a look around there's
snow everywhere on the ground here we're
surrounded by mountains it's bitterly
cold minus eight at least today and so
the real Focus here is on keeping warm
so that's a massive challenge for these
communities because not only do they
have to contend with the Damage Done by
the earthquake but also for the cold
weather and keeping themselves safe
going forward
well here in a city in ruins the cold
only makes people even more desperate
for help let us show you what we can see
this afternoon uh there may be flimsy
tents to the world but to these families
they are home at least for now
up to 25 people sharing just a few
square feet it's um thin canvas walls
protecting them from the elements and
it's bitterly cold here at night
Aid workers come three or four times a
day sometimes every hour with steaming
pots of soup or rice or both but apart
from that there is little to protect
these people from the depths of winter
as you can see the Brazier in front of
us as we walk down this road this Avenue
of this tented City their homes are gone
many only have the clothes they stand up
in
one gentleman we met earlier can't even
stand up he is bowed by the strength of
the earthquake and the subsequent damage
to his property
they've only been here for a couple of
days these people also but many people
we spoke to are already weary Unsure how
long this will need to be their homes
I'm not sure if we can make our way past
this Brazier or not as Nathan shows you
more
of the tents here we've got something
like 1500 people here at the moment
they've only been here as I say for a
couple of days children gathering around
us uh earlier a welcome destruction I
suppose we were from the monoti monotony
of their surroundings 1500 people as I
say cramped together in a car park of
the city museum that's what we're seeing
they're assured that more and more
foreign aid is on the way the UK
dispatching search and rescue teams
along with similar measures from many
other countries but these people need
more they've escaped with their lives
from their crumbling homes now they need
food more substantial shelter and hope
for the moment and also for the future
for those in Syria this week's
destruction I'm lost excuse me sir
excuse me is a crisis that we are
hearing about within a crisis the
situation only will worsening the lives
of those allegedly living in a ghost
cities shelled out and damaged by the
country's 11-year Civil War
while some Aid is starting to reach
parts of turkey in Syria the situation
is quite different more than a decade of
turmoil dramatically limiting the path
for help many of the hardest hit areas
are in the northwest of the country
which is controlled by Rebel groups the
Assad government only allows United
Nations Aid to enter the region through
one border crossing at Barb alhauer but
this route was damaged by the earthquake
hampering the relief efforts
uh for thousands of syrians already
displaced by the horror of the war
homelessness again let's get more
information from Alex Rossi
she is alive but only just
with her skin raw from cold and Trauma
she's kept warming an incubator
just hours ago she was plucked from the
rubble still attached by umbilical cord
to her mother who was crushed to death
in the earthquake
the girl has a large bruise on her back
and it's swollen there are also bruises
on the rest of her body the doctor says
and this is the moment she was rescued
an orphan at Birth the only Survivor of
her immediate family her tragedy is the
story of countless other children in a
disaster which continues to get worse
in many areas of Syria they are still
trying to scrape away at the piles of
rubble looking for survivors
it's no easy task in a place already
devastated by more than a decade of War
the search has been hampered by a lack
of heavy equipment
and getting supplies to the rebel-held
areas cut off from much of the outside
world is frustrating the humanitarian
response
Damascus says Aid must pass through its
territory if it's to enter the country
and the only workable route bypassing
the regime through turkey is badly
damaged
and need is growing by the hour there
are so many injured here waiting for
treatment
about 70 of the patients that we're
receiving are children this is horrific
you can imagine that our health care
infrastructure here is already collapsed
after the 12 years of war there's severe
funding costs we were already struggling
this is before this crisis hit us right
now our hospitals are not coping our
doctors are totally overwhelmed we've
been working flat out without sleep
since the earthquake hit I mean it's
just it's just disastrous
yeah
as the search goes on the number of dead
keeps Rising
the sound of grief is reverberating
across this region
and it is distressing yeah
this is Ahmad Idris and At His Feet
covered with blankets are the 25 members
of his family
all of them killed in an instant when
the earthquake struck without warning
he takes the body of his grandson in his
arms it's simply heartbreaking the
weight of suffering too much to bear
we fled the war look at the Injustice
that pursues us and what happened to us
we came here on the basis of finding a
safe shelter for us and our children but
in the end look how faith has caught up
to us here
they will keep searching but the
devastation that sweeps as far as the
eye can see is a constant reminder of
how much the teams on the ground have
left to do
the next few hours will be crucial but
in Syria as elsewhere hope is fading of
finding more survivors
Alex Rossi Sky News
12 thousands of syrians already
displaced by the horror of war now the
homeless are once again because of the
earthquake major International efforts
to get Aid to the worst affected are
underway our correspondent uh yusra El
begier flew on an aid flight from an air
base near Doha the capital of Qatar it
landed here in gazian Tep where the much
needed packages are to be handed out and
that user joins us live now and you've
been hearing from people already
displaced by War now without homes again
yeah Mark I mean just as we've been
standing here they've signaled that they
found two bodies and they're using
blankets to cover the area as they pull
out unfurl body bags and start to move
bodies into the body bags and we've been
at this site all day our body was
removed from the rubble earlier there
was a son and daughter screaming with
with tears as they found out that their
mother had been killed by the earthquake
and just now more bad news more
devastating news for the people that
have been waiting here all day who've
not only lost their homes but have lost
their families and we've seen you know
the stages of grief pass through this
site in the morning there was a shock a
sort of a hopeful silence and then that
turned into anger and now just share
excruciating grief that the loss not
only of loved ones but also of homes and
as you said people have fled war and
come here to gaziantep this is a city
synonymous with providing refuge for for
people fleeing being the war in Syria
and now again they've spoken to us and
they've said that this has brought them
back to that memory of being called
being homeless and not knowing where to
go
thank you very much indeed joining me
now is Paul Taylor who is international
operations manager of uh react uh the
charity and the scale of this charity of
this tragedy pool I mean it must make
things so difficult for you yes it does
um and the only thing I've got is a
point of reference is very similar for
me to Nepal in 2015 you know two
earthquakes one after the other lots of
aftershocks and sadly similarly the
amount of people who've lost their lives
and just a desperate need absolutely and
as we can see here
um the focus now quite rightly is on the
search and rescue and and in my
experience
um it all depends on your circumstances
you know when the building collapses on
top of you people may well be injured
yeah it depends how much air you've got
you might have an air pocket have you
got water would you and and as time gets
on the chances for them surviving are
just less and less yeah and if we can
just go in on this
um well hopeful rescue that is taking
place behind us here
um there was real optimism this morning
uh Paul because there was someone pulled
out alive and they say it is the sort of
building where and the way it's
collapsed means there could well be
voids in there but you know these
rescues going on or hopeful rescues
going on a day and night and just the
people around just watching and waiting
it's it's just I think that's a really
interesting point on people watching and
waiting and increasingly in the
humanitarian sector I think there's an
awareness of what are the psychosocial
aspects particularly for young children
you can imagine people potentially have
lost their parents they've witnessed a
building falling around them and they've
survived what does that do for that
young person so I think there's a
requirement there for support for them
as soon as they can possibly get it okay
so what sort of help are you trying to
get in here so what we're trying to do
now is after this phase as the people
are being found in places like this
we're addressing their core humanitarian
needs which are always fairly similar so
they're going to need shelter
particularly as it so cold they're going
to need water the medical needs are
going to be addressed if they're injured
and then further down the line a little
bit they're going to need food
all right well look Paul good luck with
the work you're doing thanks very much
thank you very much indeed
well on the ground the damage is
absolutely inescapable but the sheer
scale of the devastation could hardly be
more Stark than when seen from above a
series of satellites to images released
today show how towns which once stood
and now reduced to Rubble
this was the town of Azalea in gazian
step in southeast turkey last October
but take a look at it now this new
satellite image was taken yesterday
showing where properties have entirely
collapsed While others have their roofs
split off from the building below
here was the highly populated city of
nodagia this shows the downtown area
last September but see these green swipe
across and this is the situation now
buildings clearly destroyed and take a
look at the main road for example where
the white rectangles are all emergency
tents erected as part of the aid effort
and finally look here to see another
part of that same downtown nodagia the
grass area on the left now filled with
more of those emergency tents as
officials attempt to do all they can to
save lives
well it's more than 20 years since an
earthquake hit Northern turkey killing
more than 17
000 people 1999 the entire region
particularly vulnerable because of where
it sits on the planet's plates our
science editor Tom Clark explains the
tectonics of the tragedy
the initial earthquake struck overnight
on the East Anatolian fault line that
runs through southern turkey and it's
7.8 on the magnitude scale is by far the
largest in the region in living memory
this map shows the worst of the shaking
in red tracing the fault line as it runs
close to the city of gaziantep but the
power of the Quake meant it affected
hundreds of other cities and towns in
the region see here where orange and
yellow lines show significant shaking in
Syria and Tremors felt as far as Cyprus
then there are aftershocks shown here in
Orange over typical Quakes diminishing
in magnitude and frequency along the
fault line over the morning but what
makes this event so unusual is that nine
hours after the initial Quake a huge 7.5
magnitude Aftershock almost as strong as
the first happened here 100 kilometers
to the North in Cameron Morris province
as well as being violent both the
initial quake and that Aftershock were
relatively shallow in the Earth's crust
18 and 10 kilometers deep respectively
the closer to the surface the more
damage a quake will cause
turkey and Northern Syria are vulnerable
to earthquakes they sit at the junction
of four tectonic plates with fault lines
along their margins these latest Quakes
occurred on what's called a strike slip
fault the Anatolian plate is being
pushed westwards at a rate of about two
centimeters a year by the Northwood
movement of the Arabian plate and it was
the sudden release of this stress that's
built of many decades that caused this
disaster
and in geological terms it's one of
turkey's worst the town of Izmit was
shaken by a 7.6 magnitude earthquake in
1999 killing more than 17 000 but not
since 1939 as there been an earthquake
as violent where more than 30 000 people
died in a 7.8 magnitude Quake around
ersen can
but crude measures of geological Force
don't tell us much about the human scale
of this tragedy it will be days before
that becomes clearer
well for those who live here in Turkey
the sense of loss of course is
unimaginable for those who woke up in
the UK to news of the tragedy that was
unfolding overnight there was only one
real response get here and get here fast
we met ahmek illness who left his home
in South Wales to travel here to the
disaster Zone on a desperate mission to
reach his family in the remote Village
of Tut in the Taurus Mountains where he
grew up
this is the story of the Heartbreak of a
Brother's Journey
in a country in despair are Matt yelnaz
is a Broken Man
came across him amid the chaos of one of
the few functioning airports here
they made the journey from South Wales
he is desperately trying to find a way
to reach the Mountain Village he grew up
in I mean it's completely collapsed this
is what is left of his brother Ali's
house Ali is dead his wife seriously
injured and two of his children are
missing in the rubble
we decide to take him or at least to get
as close as we can
halfway there you get to call from his
surviving niece to say no one is coming
to help them Ahmed cannot bear it
once we're up in the mountains it is not
an easy Journey
we finally reached the village the
damage the reality of it all
reunited with his sister fatter the
uncontrollable grief
also waiting for him his surviving niece
sidca
[Music]
sisters ashigul and Zara that they are
looking for now
it is heartbreaking
[Music]
tells me it was a house full of joy and
love and now his family is destroyed so
Ahmed just tell me when you see this
what goes through your mind
unbelievable
I never see this I am very sharp
I never see this happen before my left
never
he says the locals want to know where
the government help is the truth is the
government is overwhelmed
what would your message be I said where
are you we need the people accommodation
with everybody's freezing they've been
only locals people they count neighbors
or friends they will try Harper where is
the government
in these remote snowy Villages they will
have a long wait
I'm very sorry for your loss yeah very
sorry
I can't believe
one man facing the enormity of it all in
this country of countless tragedies
the scale of the disaster Unleashed by
the earthquake can sometimes feel
dehumanizing we've heard many stories
here some tragic some full of Hope
as the clock ticks down on the rescue
effort Aid is beginning to arrive for
some it will prove life-saving for
others it is already too late we'll
leave you now with some of the strongest
images of the last few days
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]